foreign
I only feel comfortable initiating sex
with my husband when under the influence
of alcohol my parents died when I was 15
and 17. I've not been able to like
experience other people or myself
there's a possibility that your body is
highly attuned to relationships will get
you hurt
[Music]
this is John with Dr John deloney's show
hope you're ready for the greatest
mental health and parenting and
relationship podcast ever
ever recorded so glad that you're with
us if you want to be on the show go to
John deloney.com ask ask or give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and leave a message and
Jenna will check it out and give you a
buzz back
um don't forget an easy way to support
this show no money about 30 seconds of
your time leave a five star review uh
particularly comment on my cool clothes
and
um subscribe to the show wherever you
listen to it if you can if you watch it
on YouTube if you listen to it on
podcast Please Subscribe it helps kick
it up into the algorithms and there's
just we're finding that our retention of
the show so what that means is when
people hear it they stick around and
it's it's our metrics for people who get
the show listen to the show and then
come back and listen to the whole
episode is
um really unheard of in the podcasting
industry the industry folks who come
look at our numbers are just astounded
and so what that tells us is the more
people we can get in front of the more
people we can help and man I could care
less about the YouTube numbers I really
care about building communities where
um my kids can grow up and
be safe and be loved and have new tools
for dealing with the craziness life
throws at us so
um thank you for for subscribing thank
you for your five star reviews
all right before we jump into the show
um if you don't get your news from
marginal Revolution uh these two guys
are
um
they are right down the middle they're
all over everybody because they do use
this crazy thing called Data to point
things out and they use this crazy thing
called facts to point things out so they
are political up the middle and they
just provide insights into things in
very unique ways
um so Alex tabarak posted today
um this is Petrov day
and so I want to read this it's Petrov
day and I believe that the ability to be
calm in a state of crisis when things
hit the fan
being calm is a superpower
it helps everything this is when your
kid is throwing a temper tantrum this is
when your husband has left his underwear
on the floor again this is when your
wife says hey uh whatever
the ability to be calm is a superpower
which brings me to Petrov day here we go
today we honor stenciloff Petrov whose
calm actions in general Humanity get
this help prevent nuclear war on
September 26 1983. uh I'll skip forward
here's what happened he was the guy in
Russia during the Cold War when if you
don't remember the Cold War if you
weren't born yet though it was Russia
built some nukes and then we built more
nukes and then they built more nukes in
response to our nukes and we're like oh
yeah hold my beer we'll make even more
nukes and they're like oh yeah hold a
case of beer and then pretty soon
everyone's drunk and we got tons of
nukes everywhere right so then there was
it was mutually assured destruction if
you launch one of yours we're launching
all of ours well if you launch all of
yours I'll launch all of ours
and so then there was two people with
their fingers on the button going you
won't do it you won't do it you won't do
it and my dad grew up in a world where
he was doing nuclear weapon drills uh
because they were pointed right at us
and I'll never forget reading an
interview with a uh Russian military guy
who said
our job our our plan wasn't to defeat
America our plan wasn't to [ __ ] the
American economy
our plan was to end life on the North
American continent period and the way he
said it was so ice cold so that's the
context
and all of a sudden the guy in Russia
responsible for Manning the satellites
Manning the
um
all of a sudden the alarms go off the
U.S has fired nukes returned fire
and it goes on to say the 44 year old
lieutenant colonel in the Soviet Air
Defense Forces
uh was a few hours into a shift when
computers warned that five
intercontinental ballistic missiles had
been launched from an American base for
15 seconds I was in total shock we
needed to understand what's next the
alarm sounded
it was on and just a week before Russia
had shot down a commercial airliner full
of 269 people killing um everybody on
board including a U.S congressman so it
was already like game on game on and
there was every reason to believe that
the US just finally said you know what
screw it it's on you killed one of our
congressmen you shot down a Plane full
of citizens game on you're done
but he stayed calm
and for five nerve-wracking minutes
electronic maps and screens were
flashing as he held the phone in one
hand and an intercom in the other trying
to absorb the information
and he later explained it was a 50 50
guess but here's what he did he stayed
super calm and realized
they wouldn't fire just five missiles at
us that doesn't make any sense
the data suggests I know the alarms are
sounding everybody's screaming nuclear
war nuclear war the data suggests the
fact suggests there's a glitch in The
Matrix something's not right
and so he didn't fire back and it turns
out it was a
a mistake otherwise he would have
launched and it would have looked like a
preemptive strike by Russia with all of
their nuclear weapons and none of us
would be having this conversation
because the world would be in a nuclear
winter
and then get this he died at 77 on May
19th
in a Moscow suburb where he lived alone
on a pension and his death was not
widely reported
meaning the single person who was
responsible for being calm in this
single tensest moment ever in the
history of the earth except for maybe
when a comet hit
died quietly alone in a suburb in Russia
somewhere
and he'll be lost to the annals of
history and we're all here because he
acted calm because he was chill
so I salute Petrov on National Petrov
day all right so let's go to Lee in
Chico what's up Lee
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
I'm doing good thanks for asking you got
it what's up
uh yeah so I feel like I kind of have a
loaded question here so I'm just gonna
put it all out there and then I guess we
can piece it from there there you go
influence of alcohol
um we're High School sweethearts uh and
have been together for 17 years
um my parents died when I was fished uh
well my parents died when I was 15 and
17. my mom was at 15 my dad was at 17.
geez um
and now being you know 31
I kind of feel like my youth passed me
and uh
I've not been able to like experience
other people or myself excuse me I'm a
little like nervous no it's good you're
all good I I'm nervous too so we'll be
nervous together
perfect
um
I again I I just I also feel like
emotionally responsible for my husband
especially when he says things like I'd
be lost without you
etc etc
um well on the other hand I finally feel
like I would be okay if all this ended
now
um I used to not want to be alone
because I was abandoned
um but now I'm finally kind of
comfortable with it and uh basically I
just feel guilty for these feelings but
also angry that I didn't get to
experience life and growing up like my
peers
um so obviously there's a lot of layers
to this yeah
thanks for thanks for you've thought
through this have you been in counseling
before
I have I have been in counseling
your ability to pull this to pull these
apart in that way
um is
suggest you've already done some work on
yourself over the years is that fair
that's fair yeah cool that's awesome
um
where do you want to start
because
um
there's several there's there's some
mechanical stuff there's some failing
stuff there's some norming and some
anger stuff and then there's just like
doing it stuff where do you want to
where do you want to start
um let's start with who the hell am I
yeah let's start the air I mean um how
old were your parents when they passed
um my mom was 54 and my dad was 52. okay
I went to add on to this I was adopted
before I was even born you know why not
why not no let's just drop that in there
let's add some more that's it for me
yeah my no my parents are the ones who
raised me but okay that probably has
some identity issues in itself
well it there's a there's a possibility
that you've that your body is highly
attuned
to relationships will get you hurt
and the more weight get puts on to those
relationships the more your body
is trying to protect you is that fair
and so when your husband thinks he is
connecting with you saying
um
you're my everything you saved me you're
the you're the only one for me I can't
breathe without you
um those sound cool when they're in like
song lyrics in hip-hop videos
um for somebody whose body says hey if
you get too close
somebody dies if you get too close
somebody will leave that can on the flip
side that could be torture right
definitely
um
woven through here are you gonna leave
him
no are you done being married to him
no okay and it's okay I mean I'll say
it's okay but it's best to be honest up
front
um
can I just tell you it's okay to be
angry
if I were you I would be so pissed
yeah
I'd be pissed at my birth parents like
what what was wrong with me what was
wrong with y'all
I would be pissed at my
at My adoptive parents who clearly loved
me and took me in and then they went and
died on me screw them right and
I would be pissed that I've been with my
high school sweetheart I never even
kissed anybody else I never made out I
don't know what life was like I just got
this guy right you see what I'm saying
right your anger and frustration and and
heartbreak all real all good
foreign
you're not crazy you're not like like a
bad person
you're not a bad person wondering I
wonder would have been like to make out
with the other guy on the football team
and I got this Yahoo right that's not a
weird thing right
um you're not broken or weird or strange
have you ever talked about this with
your husband
I have and he doesn't understand we
actually had a couple of conversations
about it and he just
doesn't understand why I would
have those thoughts or you know
I don't know we're Polar Opposites right
I always tell everyone I'm loud and
obnoxious and he's quiet and reserved
except for around me obviously we get
along great
um but I just think we've experienced
this world differently
um and so it's hard for him to
understand where I'm coming from and
obviously it's hard for me to understand
where he's coming from so although we've
had had those conversations we haven't
done like marriage counseling we have
talked about it we just did a big move
so
um who are waiting to get settled and
set up with our jobs and hook and all
that stuff
um there's a lot going on right
there's a lot going on what what
precipitated this call what happened
um
that conversation granted that
conversation was a couple months ago
um I'm also again like really loud I
like outgoing I work for sales so I'm
out with people all the time and like
co-workers and
um
I don't know I feel like I've tended to
put myself in situations where
the question about what it would be like
to be with somebody else could have been
answered
um
and I I don't know if I'm like
subconsciously like putting myself there
or if it just happens or I I don't know
it's probably both in
um I wouldn't surprise me at all that
your body is screaming and yelling and
trying banging every trash can that it
can
um to get you to actually connect with
somebody
and you can put yourself in really
stupid positions to blow up your
marriage and hook up with somebody on a
business trip too
it can be both and
that makes sense
definitely
um it's real easy to help y'all been
married what seven years
seven years yeah but together for 17.
yeah
um this is this is the season when
um seven to ten years is one of the big
markers
when people start saying oh this is it
this is my life
and they start looking for ways to get
their heart rate back up or in other
words to feel alive and god it feels so
good when somebody who you're attracted
to who think you think's a little bit
funny you think is a little bit silly
um when they recognize you
yeah and when your introverted husband
comes home and
grabs a bush cardboard and puts his feet
up he's a great guy and he's lovely and
he pays the bills and he is kind and he
cares about you but I'm not alive
yeah I just wish we were a little more
alike sometimes
um so what it sounds like here I think
there is a difference between
feelings being understood and being
considered valid
and there is a chance and that's not a
chance there's a he he will never
understand
what you went through as a kid even
though y'all were together right I mean
he was with you right he was there
through all all of it I mean he
skateboarded to my mother's funeral when
his parents wouldn't take him like he's
a great great guy and I love him he's my
best friend
um which is why I feel so guilty for
feeling the way I do yeah but I don't
think it's about him I think it's about
you
I think you are trying to feel alive
again I don't think you don't like him
but you're chasing aliveness out there
if you think it's something you can go
get instead of something that you become
from the inside out
and so he's not going to understand what
he has to do is consider things valid
and what you're not going to understand
him
but you have to consider his needs and
feelings valid too does that make sense
yes and y'all desperately need
counseling not because I think your
marriage is broken or in trouble or
anything like that I think that you'll
have to come up with new ways of new
language to to speak to one of the new
ways to paint new pictures and
he's going to have to realize that he's
going to have to give on some things to
help you meet your needs
he's gonna have to go dancing and make
out in the hallway somewhere you know
what I'm saying yeah he's gonna have to
come home and you all have kids
no kids no okay he's gonna have to come
surprise you at work and pick you up for
a weekend Rendezvous like he's gonna
have he's gonna have to make that a part
of his day the same way some other guys
have to learn how to empty the
dishwasher I need some help here or help
with kids bedtime
um he's gonna have to get over himself
in some of that stuff
okay I don't understand why you need to
go to a hotel and peel the wallpaper off
with I don't care that's you that's you
being open and saying here's what I need
and him saying like I and you say I
don't know why you just want to watch
count on the couch and watch the office
again
like you're gonna have to learn how to
find Intimacy in those moments okay so
it's you all both learning each other's
need language
um what else do you avoid by drinking
because it's not just sex what else is
it
um
I'm not sure like what I'm a
I don't know maybe just
me like I just I
I'm like outgoing and I'll talk to
anybody even without yeah but that's
that's performance that is a way to keep
people at a distance from you
cause I do it too
this is the pot talking to the kettle
here
you and I can sing and dance and it lets
people feel like dude that we are so
close and that is the way I protect
myself
yeah maybe that's it of course of course
it is and it's not a bad thing being
outgoing is super fun I get into some
more zany fun situations
but I also have to be careful not to get
myself in dangerous situations
yes right
definitely because people think oh they
think this is funny and they're allowed
like this
they're probably into this
Fair
Fair
and then you think uh what would it be
like to be into this and now we're in a
mess
so what else do you drink from to hide
from what what is it that you're
avoiding when you're initiating sex with
alcohol
myself
comfortable I was
also raised in a very religious
background and my body is not my own and
so
I feel like sometimes
having alcoholic allows me
to like express myself whereas
if I'm not drinking or sober like it's
really hard to get in touch with like
that side
so I can imagine
um I mean I was raised in a strict
religious home too I get that sentiment
but you're 31 now and you've been with
this guy for 17 years married for seven
at some point you're choosing to hang on
to that narrative why
does that narrative getting you
it's not getting me anything
it's getting you something what is it
control Maybe
the illusion of and that control is
strangling you and your marriage
because there's also the other side
where your husband probably loves
drinking Leah he loves hooking up with
with two drinks Leah and he's asking
himself
what is it about me that
she has to have a few drinks too
want to sleep with me yeah you know what
I mean
um are you is there any chance you're
drinking to be able to do things you
don't normally want to do
no I'm just I guess when I included that
like outside of drinking like if my
husband initiates usually like two times
out of ten I'm like all right let's go
but
um
yeah I just I I guess it just gives me a
little
more freedom
to like express it I don't I don't
really know
um I
my guess is and I could be way off my
guess is you also drink when you're on
business trips too because it helps it
helps Grease the wheels of a fun
conversation
and it it might help you at parties to
have one or two drinks sort of pregame a
little bit and then you get there
because you're a little bit more fun and
a little bit louder here's the thing you
like that other version of yourself
is that fair
that's fair it may not be tell me if I'm
wrong
I mean here's what makes it kind of
complicated is
industry
so all business trips include alcohol
all meetings include my work involves
alcohol you know what I mean yeah it's
everywhere and it's an integral
part of like my career
um
so the the people I've I've talked to in
the past that have said the exact same
thing you have that they need to have a
couple of drinks before they can
um
have the kind of sex they want to have
with their partner
almost all of them no actually all of
them have said the path out of that was
to first stop drinking
it had less to do with sex and more to
do with I use alcohol for a number of
things
to either become somebody that I think
is a better version of myself or to get
through things that I don't normally
want to do like a party or some like
something sexual that my partner wants
to do that I'm not really into but I'll
I'll drink a couple just I can get
through it for them
um it all comes back to I'm gonna stop
drinking to avoid my life which then
means I gotta deal with my life
yeah where do I start with that
gas for that one but I know it
um so when it comes to let's let's just
pick sex as an example
the
the choice to enter into
I am going to pick action a b and c I'm
gonna do these things I like them when
we do them I have fun I like being
Reckless and silly
and tonight I'm not going to drink
every step of the way where you feel
uncomfortable or you you feel nervous or
you feel exposed or you feel too
connected for your bodies to feel safe
because it super connection means uh oh
it's about being curious about those
moments and
acknowledging those moments not trying
to avoid them
does that make sense
it will feel very clinical in some ways
um and it would help to be open with
your husband about it like hey this is
what I'm this is what I'm attempting to
do I'm attempting for the first time in
a long time to do life without drinking
and so it may be halfway through I'm
like ah we gotta go for a run all right
and be patient with me whatever
um it might not be and it might be that
you enter into that space and you have a
panic attack
and so it's it's about going there with
somebody you trust and clearly you trust
this guy truly he's he's somebody who's
safe
um my fear is you begin to live in numb
land
in UMB in a numb world
and you begin to
want to drag the fantasy that I what ifs
the questions out of a conversation with
your husband and into reality
and I will tell you with all of my heart
that will not fix the big giant hole
inside of you
it will blow up
everything
yeah
wonder is fun and wonder is cool and
wonder is frustrating and wonders
heartbreaking I wonder if I wonder what
would have been I wonder whatever
um
keeping that a secret will kill you and
going through it will blow up everything
when you said
you wouldn't care if this all ended what
did you mean
well you talked about being numb just
kind of going through the motion that's
where I feel like I'm at
I've been going through these emotions
for so long you know
parents house in high school okay what's
the goal finish High School all right
now I gotta go to college okay College
all right now I've got to find a job get
the career okay have the career all
right well uh we've been together for so
long let's get married because it's the
only thing that makes sense if we're
living together okay did that so now
it's like all of those things have
completed check them off the to-do list
if you will and now I'm just stuck here
like 16 years later like what the what
the heck am I doing and again what if it
wasn't like that
and what okay hold on but it is
that what if
is not helpful
because it is
the what if like what if I dated
somebody else what if I those are all
like interesting rabbit Trails the what
if I hadn't done my life like this is
not helpful the only question there
that's helpful is what is my life going
to look like tomorrow
because that's the only thing you can
toggle that's the only thing you can
adjust
so where do you start
Lee what do you want
I just wouldn't be happy what does that
even mean
I want my what ifs and what if not what
if that's the wrong word to use
I want me considering other people I
want that to be me and my husband
thank you
that makes sense you know what I mean
like it doesn't make sense say it again
I want my relationship with my husband
to be all of those things that I am
looking for in other people like I want
it to be him but it's not like I feel
like
he's like not trying like anytime we go
out I get all dressed up I do all the
things and you know when I we're talking
about uh sex and coming down to that
like I'm the one who has to like do
everything and I just
I've been doing everything my whole life
for myself or other people for my job
like why can't somebody just do
something for me
now now we're there
all the other conversation was window
dressing
he has been with you and he he
skateboarded your mom's funeral this
guy's been your ride or die for a long
time
and if you've heard
um me quote the great Esther perel most
adults have three to four to five deep
passionate loves in their adult Lifetime
and if they work really hard it's with
the same person
and what
he hasn't realized is that you
have changed
and he hasn't
and
you haven't fully told him
because you don't want to hurt him
and you're afraid he's gonna leave
have you sat down and said not I want
you to this and you never
here's what I need have you sat down and
had that conversation
no okay
I would start that conversation if I'm
you or let me put it this way I have
started this conversation with my wife
with
I haven't been telling you the truth
I have been acting like everything's
okay and it's not and that's not on you
that's on me
I haven't fully spoken my needs out loud
here's what they are
and very clear and then I have to hold
my breath because she might say I'm not
I'm not going dancing with you
I'm not whatever I'm not doing those
things I don't even understand why I
don't need you to understand why I'm
just telling you here's what I need
and
at least in my house those conversations
have been life-altering
but it started with me being honest for
the first time
so here's my homework assignment for you
okay okay
everything feels out there and in The
Ether
and it also feels very unsexy to tell
him I need you just to pick me up from
work one day and take me dancing I need
you to pick me up one day and just have
already bought concert tickets and let's
just go I need to come home one day and
you're just wearing chaps and nothing
else and I don't know what your things
are right I don't know what it is but it
feels unsexy like he should just read
your mind and know those things that are
going to complete you and it's not fair
he doesn't know
and waiting until you don't get what you
want or that he's not doing what you
have what you had hoped in your
imagination or in your fantasy world
that he was do or comparing him against
your fantasy version of your co-workers
of that good looking guy that makes good
money that's pretty funny that's funny
drunk and he thinks you're hilarious and
he says dude you look good comparing him
to that fantasy of that guy
is not fair
it's just not cool
because your picture of that guy's not
real and you're not being fully honest
with your husband
and so I want you to get a piece of
paper your homework I want you to buy a
spiral a piece of paper whatever it is
and be very specific here's what I need
and I think you've heard me say on the
show one of those things for me is me
telling my wife I need you to tell me
sometimes that you're proud of me
because all of the work I'm doing is
just trying to to make youth be
impressed
it was that literal I need you to say
the words I'm proud of you sometimes and
whenever she said them the first few
times I was like oh you're just saying
it because I told you to
but you know what it still felt good
and I had to ask myself why are you
chasing this why are you chasing her
approval
and that was a longer Journey for me to
work through on my own but it starts
with being very very specific
okay
and give him a chance
to become what you need and by the way
you give yourself a chance to actually
be fully loved 100 because you don't
you hold stuff in because you don't want
to get because the people who have loved
you in the past left you and you don't
want to give it all out because somebody
may leave again
and so you know what I'm gonna actually
cut him off
put my attention over here
and then he'll either leave or I'll have
a reason to go because it's just going
to pile up on the things he's not doing
but he doesn't even know he's supposed
to be doing whatever you just get into
this dance turn the lights on stop to
dance and say here's what I need from
you because I want us to be what's in my
head what I need right now give them a
chance
it's gonna be one of the biggest risks
of your life
and I would say almost two decades of
being together from the guy that
skateboarded down the street to make
your mom's funeral
to the guy that said I do
I think he's worth that
most importantly I think you're worth
that
stay on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of on your past change your future
I want you to read it through together
and y'all can begin to ask yourself
any of us can ask which is
what do I do now
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Chris
in D-Town Dallas Texas what's up Chris
hey Dr John how's it going partying dude
what are you up to
oh nothing much thank you for taking my
call I really appreciate it absolutely
brother what's up man how can I help
all right so my question is how can I
best support my fiance
um with her uh bipolar uh diagnosis
while also still taking care of myself
and making sure that I'm good mentally
[Music]
yeah what are y'all going through
it all started actually we've been
together five years so starting last
year
um we had pretty rough year
um
started off we lost my dad to cancer
um back in February of last year
and then
um fast forward to May
she graduated college
you know doing good looking for jobs and
then she started getting just really
really depressed like couldn't get out
of bed
um she ended up going into a manic
episode
and
ended up wanting to hurt herself we had
to hospitalize her for 10 days
and you know she's they got her
stabilized she got out and
for
probably the next four or five months
she just had little episodes about every
couple of weeks
um
I ended up quitting my job to stay home
with her
take care of her make sure she you know
didn't go out and do anything that was
going to hurt her or anything like that
and I mean that was
really really tough on me a lot of
things happen we got into a lot of
fights and you know a lot of things were
said and it was just really really tough
on me
um a lot of things you said a lot of
stupid stuff or she said a lot of stupid
stuff to you now it was a lot of mostly
I mean
that was the first time that I had dealt
with that that was the first time I went
through that with her hold on hold on I
want you to hear be I want you to pay
close attention to your distancing
language
some tough things were said
that absolves people from hurt either
you hurt somebody
and you don't like who you became in
those moments trying to take care of her
or
you didn't know she was capable of
saying some of that stuff and she hurt
you what was it
uh I mean I
honestly it was a lot of both of us
um
we both said a lot of things and did a
lot of things that you know hurt each
other and
um you know it's for me it was hard to
kind of decipher you know whether that
was actually her saying those things to
me
and that you know like I said that was
the first time I went through that and
that was just it's hard to hear a lot of
those things and so I
reacted not in the best way to it okay
and
so yeah I mean that was exactly on both
of us so are you back at work
yeah so I started a new job I ended up
you know having a hard time finding a
job
um you know I was at home for almost
four months after that after she's found
a job and you know things went back to
normal
well fast forward to about three weeks
ago
um she was in a new job for about two
months it was her dream job
she loved it it was pretty abnormal
hours
[Music]
and they kind of forced her out
they the girl that was her boss just
didn't really want her there and then
kind of gave her the option to either
leave or stay in a toxic work
environment so we talked about it
I want to make sure we're on we're that
we're
using affirmative language okay and I'll
tell you at the end while this is
important
in this current market where it's very
very hard to find employees
right
it's been my experience that people are
reticent to just like I don't like her
I'm just gonna be mean to her and try to
force her out
or can you with like clear cleaning your
glasses and looking objectively
is there a chance that your fiance was a
terrible employee she didn't show up on
time she snapped at people she had
little miniature episodes at work and it
was just too much
um I mean I don't think she was a
terrible employee uh I think it was a
learning curve for her okay she was new
to this industry and
she was learning and she wanted to learn
and they kind of
just put her in a position
that you know she either learned it on
her own or you know it didn't work out
and
I I don't think it had anything to do
with her being a bad employee
um but she but she clearly she wasn't
able to get the job that they wanted
done done
yeah yes
um
realistic expectations out of her
okay and I'll I'll say I mean yeah
ultimately here's the deal you can't
um
as much as you want to and you're a good
guy you can't fix her
right
um
I would recommend with all of my heart
not trying to fix the quote-unquote
bipolar
but instead focusing on how can I love
her and support her while she addresses
the behaviors that makes her life more
difficult
exactly if you try to go after bipolar
that's a moving Target different people
will diagnose you with different things
and bipolar one uh well the hypomania is
a little bit low so we're going to roll
you off to bipolar too the meds are just
throwing spaghetti at the wall sometimes
and so
there's a lot of toggling and a lot of
fixing and if you can get somebody who
is truly bipolar one uh in my part two
two but to to take their meds
you can see some extraordinary success
yeah and it's still going to be lows and
still going to be Highs but it does make
life much easier to live you know what I
mean right
and that's I mean that's the reason for
what happened last year she got off of
her Med she didn't like how they made
her feel and you know she got off of
them and then that happened okay and you
know I've really tried to been on be on
her you can't you can't man you can't be
on her you're not her dad
you're somebody who loves her
yeah and it's hard because you
the longer I well that's a parenting
analogy I don't do that
the more you intervene
and confirm to her that she has broken
and damaged and unable to care for
herself in any capacity
the more you come in and try to take
over and quote unquote be on her about
taking her stuff and doing the right the
more you do that the more her ability to
get with her doctor and to follow her
doctor's plans and to build that
resilience and that muscle and just
atrophies over time
the helplessness increases
does that make sense
no yeah that definitely makes sense
um what what often
not always and again I I would want to
talk to her and make sure she's got the
right psychiatric care
often the greatest gift you can give
somebody
who is struggling with mental health
with their mental health challenges
particularly in something like
schizophrenia something like bipolar one
of the schizoaffective disorders is that
you be very very well
meaning you set the mark for I am never
going to miss a day of exercise I'm
gonna get plugged into a spiritual
Community I'm going to have my own
friends I'm going to eat as best as I
can I'm gonna have where I'm going to do
work that matters I'm not going to owe a
bunch of people money so I'm not
stressed all the time
and what you're doing is you're creating
an environment of peace that often
somebody with bipolar doesn't even
understand it's different air
it's a it's a purity of oxygen they've
never breed before
and instead of you bringing your chaos
to an already chaotic environment and
trying to demand Clarity in that chaotic
environment doesn't work
all right see what I'm saying
yes yeah and it feels like let me put it
this way and this is going to sound
harsh
um
if you said I'm going to love you every
day but I'm not going to call you and
check up on you every day and see if you
took your meds I'm going to trust you
and
I know that you've been diagnosed with X
or Y in this relationship you we cannot
lie to one another
period we have to tell the truth or I
have to ask myself hard questions about
being married to somebody who doesn't
tell the truth
you cannot hit me you cannot go off on
three-day disappear for three days or
five days and end up with somebody that
we used to know and then just roll it up
like
that might be a function of your
disorder that might be a function of
some of your manic behaviors that is not
something I'm going to tolerate in this
relationship so if you want to be in
this relationship with me
you're gonna have to be extra
um direct with your psychiatrist get to
be extra intentional about taking your
medication you have to be extra
intentional about being honest with me
you see what I'm saying I'm taking
bipolar off the table I'm dealing with
these behaviors because what you're
going to do is you're going to you're
going to end up her dad
right that's exactly how I feel right
and that's not your job your job is to
love her
be her partner not her father
and you can also find yourself after
your dad passed away
suddenly the world feels a lot less a
lot less in control it feels out of
control feels chaotic and Mayhem and
dude I'm going to tighten my grip on
this one relationship that I got left
and what you end up doing is you tighten
your grip so much you strangle the whole
thing
yeah I mean that's exactly how I feel
like I feel like what I'm doing right
now
it's not working
do what it's not working
no not at all I just I just feel like
I'm
pushing her away when I'm not meaning to
yes
yes and it's just falling apart right
underneath my nose you know yes so
here's the exercise for you
okay stop looking at her like she's some
sort of dysfunctional broke down car
that you've gotta
walk nine miles to a gas station with
one of those rad guests red gas cans to
fill up with gas
she is a person a friend your girlfriend
you love her
she'll probably laugh like crazy when
she's up I bet she is a rocket ship to
be around huh
very much so yeah like the funnest my
favorite friends I've got are my bipolar
friends when they're up they're a riot
dude it's incredible
um and it makes me forget sometimes the
totality of our relationship
because when things are bad they're real
real bad
yeah right exactly so
I want you to stop looking like she
can't think for herself and do for
herself and exist for herself and I want
you to have a crazy conversation ask her
this this question
um say hey I've been trying to act like
your dad and I don't know how this
happened I'm just trying to love you and
I'm a good Texas male and so I try to
Love by
um dominating and I'm not gonna do that
anymore I love you too much
how can I best love you right now
ask her that question
okay what do you need from me
and then tell her I'm used to telling
you to take your meds every day on that
you know that I'm not going to do that
that's between you and your doctor I'll
go with you to the appointments if you'd
like
um but at the end of the day you've got
to want to be well
[Music]
and for her meds might be a part of her
life forever they might just be
um great cool
I'm not going to lose sleep over that
we're just going to make that a part of
our life and if they start to make her
not feel good then we're going to find
different ones we're not just going to
quit because we know what happens when
we quit right but again she's got to
want that
and you're gonna have to practice not
trying to Lord over but you're gonna
have to practice being with
and that means you're gonna have to have
boundaries that when you show up and
she's seven beers in
you say I told you I I'm not interested
in being around you and you're drunk
um we you say things I say things
um I'm stepping out of this if you go
I'm gonna that you're you're gonna make
those choices I love you with all my
heart but I'm also going to hold these
boundaries right all right right that's
exactly how that goes right
yep yes or she calls you at 2AM and says
I want you to come over and I need to be
with you right now and you say I'm I've
got to sleep because I got work
um doesn't mean I don't love you it
means that I gotta take care of myself
if you don't come over right now I'm
gonna call so
if you do that that's great you're
opting out of relationship with me but
I'm going back to bed I love you
right
yeah here's the other side Chris
she might call that guy
she might get super super drunk
and you might have to call 9-1-1 but you
can't be your dad
right
right you don't like that do you
no it's just not that I don't like it
it's just it's gonna be something that I
just have to work on and
something we're gonna have to talk about
and
um we we got into therapy and
we were doing great and then another
episode happened and our therapist was
just like
you know I don't know enough about your
about her situation I think y'all should
find somebody else
and kind of just left us hanging there
so you know we're gonna look into
somebody else get back into therapy and
just figure this out okay
um
at the end of the day all only person on
planet Earth you can control is you your
thoughts and your actions
your boundaries and your choices that's
it that's it that's it that's it that's
it that's it
that's it
so make the decision to ask yourself
what are the things I need to do to be
well
what are my boundaries forget the
bipolar diagnosis
what are my boundaries you cannot tell
me you hate me you cannot tell me to go
blank myself you cannot
um sleep with somebody it's not like
that's that's you can't get super high
or super coked up and run around the
neighborhood like you can't do these
things
I won't I won't be in partnership with
somebody I won't commit my life
romantically to somebody I won't try to
build a life with somebody who is unable
to be Integris be a person of fidelity
and I will love you but I can't be your
dad
[Music]
and that's going to be hard hard hard
for you I think all this starts with you
asking her that one magic question how
can I best love you
because the way I'm trying to have loved
you for the last five years isn't
working let's I want to try something
new
and you my brother are gonna have to
practice
[Music]
opening your hand up
saying I love you and here's my boundary
appreciate your heart man
gotta do something different this time
and yes go find another therapist one
that will stick with you guys and that
no better knows how to
teach people the skills of loving one
another when somebody's got bipolar it's
out there it exists you can't have a
happy marriage it's gonna work at it
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloney
to get 10 off your order today
all right we are back let's go to
Catherine and Lexington what's up
Catherine
uh Dr Delaney I deeply appreciate you
speaking with me today I appreciate you
calling in how can I help
so my question is I have a 30 year old
son almost 31 who has struggled with
addiction mental illness for the past
nine ten years
and
I've just become so frustrated that I
I'm wondering is it ever okay to just
say hey don't contact me
until you've been sober for a year or
some amount of time
yes
and
my mind knows that's okay but how do I
tell the rest of me my heart and my
emotions and I mean because it's been a
roller coaster for you know years is is
what's he running from
[Music]
so that was back in 2007
um
my daughter and I handled it you know
we talked to each other but he would
just be completely shut down if you
cried about it it was just like you
could see him trying to run out of the
room and at the time you know I went to
therapy and they recommend they did not
recommend me forcing him
because he's saying you know that's not
going to help if he's unwilling
and now I feel like he's unwilling to
stick with anything in his life you know
I mean he's just he's been in and out of
psychiatric hospitals treatment centers
homeless
and it's heartbreaking yeah and I you
know I know
from my own counseling and from trying
to be healthy myself that I can't
control what he's doing but I just don't
know how to sit with it and accept it
maybe that's the better yeah thing
um
and I feel like the resources in our
country are pretty
it's just super hard when he gets in a
hospital and still
things happen and he doesn't get help
it's just you know it's
it's a struggle because there's just not
much to do to help somebody no matter
how mentally ill he seems yeah and it
sounds like he's dealing less with
mental health issues and more psychosis
he has I mean he has struggled with both
but it's very hard for me to tell you if
it's more a drug thing or a mental
health thing I truly believe he has
mental health issues
but because he continuously turns to
drugs it's it's hard to know yeah when
those tend to braid together over time
to where it's so hard to extrapolate you
really have to have a period of intense
true sobriety to pull that apart
sometimes that's just so hard to get to
um and I mean we've tried having him at
home with us trying to make sure he sees
a psychiatrist but ultimately so some of
his psychosis
is kind of terrifying you know he's told
me before I I want to kill the person
who's taken over my mom and he's talking
to me that's right and my my daughter is
a police officer and she sends me things
you know saying please don't let him be
at home people get killed that way you
know and it just
my mind again I come back to my mind
knows it's not safe but my heart
is just having a real hard time with it
and I would tell you that you're right
on both counts
you have a right to be safe
you have a right to your boundaries
you have a right to not be threatened
you have a right to have your home not
stolen like robbed right
you have a right to not have drugs in
your home or to have vomit and urine all
over the place you have a right to that
and
God it's heartbreaking
to have my son yeah both of those things
are true and what you're trying to do is
have one without the other and you can't
and so where I would start if I I'm
trying to just think think ahead here
um
number one I can't I can't even wrap my
head around it
um
because I know like you I'd go to the
ends of the Earth for my kids
right the end of time like I have but it
hasn't changed anything exactly that's
just it so the first thing you've got to
do
is write Catherine a letter
okay
and the first line of that letter is
Catherine it's not your fault
because you're still harboring some
guilt that somehow if you had done
something a little different or done of
things this way or that way or had to
listen to this one piece of advice for
this one all of this would be different
yes that's true and that kind of
thinking I get it it's not helpful
because here's where we are right now
and when we live into that guilt and in
your case I
should have done something different
turns into uh um I did something dumb or
I wish I'd done something different
turns into I'm a bad mom
this is my fault
if he dies that one's on me
yes and that's the difference between
guilt and shame
okay I can sit down with you and tell
you things I should have said
differently to my son Hank my daughter
Josephine there's a few things that will
haunt me till I die
I wish I'd said this differently or not
done this one
and the more I dwell on that the more I
intentionally disconnect myself from
myself and from them in in the present
it does no good right it's not helpful
I learned my lesson and I think I'm a
good dad
and I'm gonna believe that you're a good
mom
yeah and so first letter is to Catherine
it's not your fault here's the things
that happened
I don't hold anybody accountable for the
decisions they make after their husband
up and just dies
yeah
there's trauma on top of trauma and
suddenly you're a single mom in Kentucky
in the middle of an economic meltdown I
mean you know what I'm saying
right you've got to give that Catherine
some Grace
the second letter goes to your son
you're never going to give it to him
but it's going to be to that 15 year old
little boy who lost his dad
yeah
and you're going to tell them the things
that you've been swirling around in your
head for the last 10 15 years that you
didn't say that you still haunt yourself
with
um you're gonna say those things
okay okay and then here's the third
letter
it might be one you consider sending
this is one that will be here are my
boundaries moving forward
it will not be okay to come to my house
if you've been using period you're not
welcome here I'll call the police
you're not welcome which I have done yes
yeah
um
your access to my money is and anyone in
our family's money is zero we will not
give you any more money this is a hard
conversation and we're having it right
now
if he's homeless and I don't know I mean
I don't I really couldn't send that
letter because I don't know where he is
right that's that's keep it to yourself
but okay you don't have to send it what
I'm saying is it's important to get
those boundaries out of your head and
onto paper it's like making a budget
like when I when I'm I bought a guitar
yesterday and
I'm not gonna lie Catherine it's an
incredible guitar but I started doing
some I started doing the math in my head
the math in my head is very different
than my budget in reality you know what
I mean
like I think I spent this last week
about a scope for a new rifle the other
day so I got this yeah I think we're
yeah I think we're good
Captain we are not good not good at all
right so the more those boundaries swirl
around on your head the more likely you
are to make an impulse purchase
the more likely you are to be exhausted
on a Friday night be two beers and a
whole pizza into a Friday evening and he
shows up and you're like just go to the
back room and go to bed
yeah and now we're back into square one
again all your boundaries mean nothing
he knows that
um now you gotta repaint the bathroom
and you've got to fix the sheets and you
gotta you know what I'm saying all that
so have your boundaries written down so
that you are very clear you might get
somebody to do it with you
maybe your daughter maybe somebody
whoever's somebody you trust my husband
now is very good at helping with that
although he's given it a try to help him
as well he's good with the boundaries
he's he's a good support for me because
he sees that we need the boundaries
there you go but and that helps me
here's something important Catherine he
can't write the boundaries he's got to
just support you while you do it yes and
and that's true and I understand that
because you'll get mad at him at 2 A.M
if you haven't been the one that set
these boundaries right correct yes
that's 100 right so you do the hard work
of writing them down and then you'll
have to build an ecosystem where
Catherine you have to decide you're
worth being well
you have to decide you're worth a great
marriage
you're worth laughing going to play
bingo I don't know what you do in
Lexington Kentucky go ride horses I
don't know what y'all do
um but that you have to not cash out of
your life because your son isn't doing
well and is has
uh bias choices and just by virtue of
his illness
um has become unsafe to be around
do this he can get the help he needs if
he chose to correct I've had some people
in recovery tell me
that he can it's just he's not
doing the steps to get there because I
always want to feel his mental illness
is so bad that he can't do any
differently than what he's doing and
maybe I'm making an excuse no I I think
it's both and
um I stopped a long time ago
pointing my fingers at people who are
struggling with addiction
and struggling mental health
um I used to say why I can't believe
someone would do meth and not and walk
away from their kids that person sucks
now I think to myself
God Almighty what what happened to that
person what's what has gotten into their
soul that the only way they can get
through a day is with methamphetamine
yeah and it's a much more empathetic
approach but it doesn't change my
boundaries you cannot come inside my
home if you're high
you cannot come in my house if you are
stoned my empathy is different I'm not
judging you and I'm not angry with you
but you have to meet me halfway and
halfway is safety and sobriety
halfway is right and it might be a part
of your boundaries are you and your
husband go ahead and have a number if he
came to you and said I've been sober for
six months I've been work I've been
mowing lawns a couple days a week I'm
ready to go to rehab
y'all might have a number like we'll put
in 10 000 on that or we'll put in five
grand on that or whatever you may have
that go ahead and set that aside in your
boundaries
um
and give him something to lean into
but he is choosing to not be in
relationship with you not the other way
around
that is true okay you are not choosing
to kick your son out of your house
because he can't get his crap together
that's not what we're doing
oh sure he is opting
out of relationship with you for
whatever reason and that is the most
heartbreaking thing a parent can
experience as their kids opting out for
whatever reason addiction mental health
all that yes there are resources and yes
I dare say there are people that could
help him if if he made the decision to
go I also would say there are moments
when the Mental Health Plus
the wrong meth fentanyl combination I do
believe there's some moments when you
melt some circuitry and it's just I
don't know you get it back
yeah
I see that
that's super intelligent growing up and
I can tell that it's definitely changed
and he might have undiagnosed
schizophrenia and drugs helps him get
through it it helps clarify things a
little bit
I do think that's one of the diagnoses
he's been given in the past if he's got
schizophrenia you don't stay somewhere
long enough right to ever know that for
sure I'm sure
um if he does have schizophrenia and and
he could actually go get stabilized and
get the right medication and get on a
routine for 30 60 90 120 days you'd see
a different human being this is hard to
get there
it's hard to get someone else to do that
that's right we've we've tried to
regulate meds and yeah it's all that
it's like my last caller right it's it's
at some point somebody's got to decide
I don't know how this works and I know
that I'm I'm having hallucinations and
I'm hearing voices but I want to
have a different life
man that's hard that's hard that's hard
that's hard that's hard
especially all of this makes sense to me
and I'll just you know I
I know the boundaries thing is important
and safety yeah I mean so it's a safety
issue I want you to get a journal and
every time you feel super heartbroken
you feel that Mom guilt you feel that
wave of I failed him write that down
write those feelings down and challenge
them is that true
have you been a terrible Mom did you
really fail him
I bet the answer is no
is your son sick absolutely is it
heartbreaking yes does he have
permission to threaten to kill you no
[Music]
is it devastating to know your kid is
homeless
especially when there's medications out
there that could probably help him that
there's treatment plans and people that
would help him oh my gosh I can't I
can't wrap my head around how
devastating that would be
and yet I have to know the limits of my
own power and I can't drag somebody
kicking and screaming
to their own Wellness
[Music]
tart
it's hard it's hard it's hard it's hard
I'm sorry it's just as just parent to
parent I'm sorry
[Music]
you're a good mom Catherine
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well-life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
thanks for being with us and for hanging
out with us all day this is some heavier
calls today answer calls that don't have
a lot of great endings to them
um or at least not right now uh maybe
over time and so sometimes that is the
messiness of life
but luckily
we've got these two brothers from
London is that a good voice no
it's like
they're not from London anyway they're
from Manchester they're really big about
that
they're from Over the lake across the
pond
said the stupid American it's over there
the boy the songs that uh the two
brothers that ruined every campfire for
every girl in the 90s and early 2000s
Oasis
made every frat boy on planet Earth
think they were going to be a
singer-songwriter with their classic
Champagne Supernova it goes like this
how many special people change how many
lives are living strange where were you
well we were getting high slowly walking
down the hall faster than a cannonball
where were you well we were getting high
this is actually a question Kelly asked
me all the time someday you'll find me
caught beneath a landslide in a
Champagne Supernova in the sky I don't
even know what that means but I do know
this I'm grateful for you we'll see you
soon
[Music]